Fourth, we're designing smart therapeutics that can do calculations within the body
and go far beyond current medicines,
which are really blunt instruments.
For example, to target a small subset of immune cells
responsible for an autoimmune disorder,
and distinguish them from the vast majority of healthy immune cells.
Finally, inspired by remarkable biological materials
such as silk, abalone shell, tooth and others,
we're designing new protein-based materials
to address challenges in energy and ecological issues.
To do all this, we're growing our institute.
We seek to attract energetic, talented and diverse scientists
from around the world, at all career stages,
to join us.
You can also participate in the protein design revolution
through our online folding and design game, "Foldit."
And through our distributed computing project, Rosetta@home,
which you can join from your laptop or your Android smartphone.
Making the world a better place through protein design is my life's work.
I'm so excited about what we can do together.
I hope you'll join us,
and thank you.
(Applause and cheers)